اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من الجليل
الاعلى اهلا بكم الجزيره ترصد الاوضاع في
مناطق شمال قطاع غزه بعد انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منها واشتباكات عنيفه
في مدينه غزه تزامنا مع قصف متواصل وجيش
الاحتلال يعلن قتل اربعه عسكريين بينهم
ضابطان احدهما رائد في وحده شال داغ
النبويه واصابه نحو 15 اخرين خلال الساعات
الاخيره وزاره الصحه في غزه تقول ان
الاحتلال ارتكب 15 مجزره راح ضحيتها اكثر
من
118 شهيدا خلال الساعات ال 2 الماضيه
وتقول ان اكثر من 30 الف فلسطيني بمدارس
قريبه من مجمع ناصر الطبي بلا ماء او طعام
الجزيره ترصد شهادات فلسطينيين تعرضوا
للتعذيب اثناء اعتقالهم من قبل جيش
الاحتلال خلال توغله في
القطع مع تسارع الحديث عن فرص امكانيه
التوصل الى صفقه تبادل نتنياهو يقول انه
يسعى للتوصل الى اتفاق لكن ليس باي ثمن
ومسؤولون اسرائيليون يتهمونه بالسعي
لافشال الصفقه من جانبه يقول كيربي ان
واشنطن تسعى لهنه طويله ومسؤولون يتحدثون
عن ضغط امريكي نحو اتفاق هدنه طويله الامد
يوقف الزخم العسكري
الاسرائيلي قوات الاحتلال تقتحم مدنا
وبلدات فلسطينيه عده وتصيب فلسطينيين في
طوباس وثالثا في اطلاق نار على مركبه
فلسطينيه قرب منطقه المحول وسط الخليل
ومواجهات بين قوات الاحتلال وشبان
فلسطينيين في بلده حزمه شمال شرقي القدس
ونادي الاسير يقول ان الاحتلال اعتقل 44
فلسطينيا
منذ امس الى
اللقاء